is it a circus is it a concert is it a
political rally no it's the annual open
dates at the European Parliament in
Brussels and that makes it a bit of all
three a whimsical musical collaboration
kicked to show off in the debating
chamber followed by an actual debate on
this year's theme United in diversity
guest of honour was Ali fares at the
Syrian satirical cartoonist and winner
of the Sakharov Prize for freedom of
thought in 2011 there was plenty of
scope for the public to join in
what did some of the thousands of
visitors make of it but everything
that's happening with the refugee crisis
it's so important that we don't close
our borders to people who desperately
need our help
there's a lot of let's say borrowing of
good things from one corner of the you
to the other only oprah bar demand aloha
don't pathetically for every Marvel fare
her personal hope the event marks Europe
Day and the declaration on EU unity by
one of its founding fathers robert
schumann in 1950 sixty-six years later
the idea is to invite citizens to feel
that spirit divisions over refugees and
the economy notwithstanding